jetzt kommt genau
wir haben uns wieder ausgedacht wie
können wird sich ärgern wie können wir
dich bauch pinseln also nett zu dir sein
man kann es selber auswählen wie immer
und greift zu dem schlechten und wenn
das beste kommt zum schluss einfach
abdrehen
genau so und jetzt kannst du saufen
er wird so sommer denn du bist der
jüngste von drei brüdern hat man es als
küken einfacher nein das stimmt nicht
ich bin nicht der jüngste ich habe nur
einen kleinen bruder und meine kleine
schwester noch mehr elan sie kann sicher
also ich habe in der bio steht der
jüngste daneben aber die beiden wieder
junge ich bin der jüngste von dem halbes
jahr wichtig aber in der familie bin ich
die goldene mitte
und so ist es am besten hat zwei kleine
zwei große und du bist jetzt bestimmte
antwort auf wie ist es als jüngste in
der gruppe
kannst du mal also da wird jeder gleich
behandelt man nicht so walter jederzeit
jedes gleich bei uns das böse würden ja
mal gucken wir wollen wir ein bisschen
die eine rein wirken als der kleine
bruder ist noch ganz gelungen ständig in
frage
okay das wortspiel mut sehr spannend nur
mit dem schlechten anfang denn man kann
nicht schlimmer es kommen das stimmt ja
so andere rapper parodieren
aber selbst im rap kommerziell
erfolgreich sein wollte ist das kein
widerspruch in sich
das denken viele leute aber ich weiß wie
ich parodieren andere rapper aber ich
liebe tiere die mehr
ja also ich parodieren die ja nicht die
tiere die und das offene beziehung
gehabt
also ich beleidige niemanden oder so was
ich hiermit ihre witzigen ja klar
natürlich manche verstehen das nicht
manche sind halt die denken man hat was
gegen die aber mit dem parodien habe ich
euch meine kunst gezeigt und zwar dass
ich jeden nachmachen kann und jetzt rap
ich selber und bist original und bin
eure china aber mit dem widerspruch in
sich von wer darauf hinaus gibt das
überhaupt kann sich jemand ernst nehmen
wenn du jetzt ernst merkt dass die
komisch sagt ernst nehmen ernst nehmen
kann man sowieso niemand weil er
irgendwas also ernst nehmen soll man
jemanden nicht weil er sagt weil ein
video mit 100 leuten rum läuft oder so
gebaut dass weil cannabis zu sich nimmt
kann man sowieso keine man nicht kennt
so ich mache gute musik von mir aus
könnt ihr mich nicht ernst nimmt mich
nicht ernst aber das ist gute musik
mache das kann keiner widersprechen
wir sind hier in der branche musik und
nicht in der branche ernst ling und
deswegen wenn die meine musik gefällt
dann kaufte ihm ein album
wenn ihr meine musik nicht gefällt dann
etwas anderes sehr gut also haben wir
zuerst wieder eine große wieder eine
rote
das video wird da ganz langweilig solche
grüne demnach in rote brücke oder nach
einer grün erst neben kommen erstmal
guten also eine über unsere schlimmste
frage
die lassen wir als letztes genau kommt
zum schluss dass es ja ich habe sie
gelesen aber ich hab das dann auch mal
so im kopf hat dann arbeitsstelle waren
gut es waren gute böse war okay du
machst neben deiner rap karriere und dem
youtube kanal auch noch ein studium wie
bringst du das alles unter einen hut
es ist schwer auf jeden fall aber wie
gesagt jetzt pausiere ich gerade mein
studium das heißt für das album habe ich
mir ein urlaubssemester genommen aber es
ist stressig bin ich studiere dann dann
geht das auch keine rolle
dann habe ich viel zu viel zu tun aber
deswegen pause genommen und ich versuche
das jetzt einfach mal
ein halbes jahr verloren ist nicht die
welt es geht weiter mit den grünen
fragen auch zwei grüne und dann die rote
zum schluss dass ich hier
grün ist die farbe des paradieses beim
westeuropäern mehr so die die hoffnung
des grünen grün ist unsere der villa das
team gebremst habe genau das ist die
farbe des islams sozusagen ein
waschechter youtube-star könntest du dir
vorstellen auch ohne social media so
viel erfolg zu haben
social media schwierig heutzutage weil
ich zu sein ist sehr schwierig weil
fernseher ist nichts mehr da kommt man
auch nicht mehr so einfach rein also
ohne youtube glaube ich würde das nicht
so funktionieren wie es jetzt
funktioniert aber es ist bei den meisten
soll jeder wird durch youtube bekannt zu
tage wir sehen dass wir bei unseren
anderen youtuber habt unsere kollegen
bei schalke folie also der heybeli alexy
bakterielle freund durch youtube kommt
ins fernsehen
und ja ohne ohne youtube ist schwierig
internet ist die zukunft
hertha wo man bekannt werden könnte gibt
es auf youtube weil sie warum weil sich
da aussuchen können was sie gucken
wollen
letzte grüne dann kommt diese
unglaublich gute frage
da bin ich mal gespannt wann weiß
ausbrüche so du hast mittlerweile einen
ziemlich großen eine ziemlich große
fangemeinde gemeinde wie stolz macht es
dich ein teil der abi brüder zu sein
auf jeden fall es macht mich stolz ich
freue mich natürlich sagte sicher voll
peinlich oder so so ist es nicht
ich bin stolz was wir geschafft haben
wir haben es aus eigener hand gemacht da
hat uns keiner läufen und deswegen kann
man nur stolz drauf sein und es können
uns auch viele viele jeder gönnt uns
dass und jeder ist stolz auf uns alle
unsere freunde und die ganzen leute die
freuen sich alle auf das was wir machen
das gesamtpaket stimmt das glaube ich
auch diesen erfolgreich und hoffentlich
dann album dann auch gangster ingenieur
das iftar nicht verletzt nach dem motto
dem ingenieur ist nichts zu schwör frage
du hattest bisher nur erfolgt durch
parodien hast du angst davor mit ernsten
texten zu flotten wie gesagt angst nicht
ich habe nichts zu verlieren außer dass
flächen die hose geht aber diese paar
tausend euro scheiß dich drauf ist
einfach eine sache für mich und es wird
vielleicht nicht so klein krachen aber
ganz floppen wird es glaube ich auch
nicht
ich bin sehr gespannt also ich drücke
die daumen dankeschön und ihr drückt
hoffentlich auch die daumen also
unbedingt wittmanns amazon itunes und so
weiter man in der video beschreibung
haut rein es geht um youtube und da
stehen wir schließlich immer alle
zusammen sollten wir zumindest alle
zusammenhalten
ich finde es toll dass hier auch eben
aus youtube und ohne riesen
marketingmaschine sein sollte rap machen
und das auf einem ziemlich ordentlich
niveau da können sich einigen
vom abschneiden auf jeden fall ich danke
dir firma ich danke dir schöne grüße an
alle fans
bleibtreu bis dann so bleibt dran